- Sing it!
♪ Remember when you made ♪
♪ That water, that water ♪
- Boo!
- No!
(laughing)
- [Both] Hey!
- Welcome back to a new
season of Lost in Translation.
- Woo!
- As usual, we take a recipe,
we put it into Google Translate,
it goes from English to Finnish,
to Shona, and many, many, many more.
Finally, back to English to give us
this hilariously translated recipe.
And there are gonna be a ton
of surprises this season.
- So make sure to tune
in every single week
so you don't miss out.
- One thing will stay the same,
we are definitely gonna keep
torturing Jasmine, I'm sorry.
Okay, let's get you in there.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my goodness.
- Mm-hm.
- What is that?
- Oh, a surprise, surprise, like I said.
We have a new hint box
and what it means is,
we give you the hints
and special ways now.
We either have to act it,
sing it, draw it, rhyme it.
Okay, but now I have to give you
what we really came here for.
Here's the recipe.
- Thank you.
- You guys picked it.
- Pink Pancake.
(all laughing)
I'm getting sweet, but you
never know based on the title.
Why did you look at them?
- I didn't look.
I didn't.
- You literally did.
Roll back the footage.
Cute shirts everyone.
- [All] Thanks.
- It's cute shirt.
- This is the new merch
for Lost in Translation
suggested by you guys and the
comments from last season.
They're available now at shopbuzzfeed.com,
so make sure to check it
out. Now we get started.
- Let's do it.
(all cheering)
- Step number one, we prepare the team.
(Jasmine laughing)
Team. You ready?
- Yes. Yes.
- Half cup oatmeal, one
tablespoon baking powder,
quarter teaspoon baking
powder, and a pinch of salt.
Am I tearing up?
We prepare the dough.
Let me just take a look.
Jaggery powder, chickpea
flour, semolina flour.
No. Should I use a hint?
I think I might.
You know, I always do this,
but to get up on the right start,
you need a strong foundation.
Let's bring-
Do we have a hint box song?
♪ Let's bring out the hint box ♪
- Who you want a hint from?
- [Kelly] She's just staring at Mimo.
- I know, stop the staring at me.
- I will choose Mimo.
Okay.
Act it!
Round.
Cereal.
Soup?
Gum. Stretchy?
Spaghetti!
Semolina! Semolina!
(group cheering)
Based on Mimo's Oscar winning performance,
I have gone with semolina flour.
Half a cup of semolina flour,
one tablespoon baking powder,
quarter teaspoon baking powder,
and a pinch of salt.
I am gonna do, one
tablespoon of baking powder,
quarter teaspoon of baking
soda and a pinch of salt.
Gonna give this a good mix
and let's move on to step two.
Step number two,
don't forget to add four tablespoons
the boiling point water and
one tablespoon of olive oil.
So I have some boiling water,
I'm gonna add in four tablespoons
and one tablespoon of olive oil.
Kelly and Katie are
both pregnant right now,
babies about to pop any time.
- Kelly could go into labor during this.
- Literally she could.
Okay, this is mixed together.
All right.
Step number three, mix the cookie dough,
put on tile and attach the film.
15 minute break.
I didn't make any cookie dough,
so I feel like there's no
way I can mix something
I haven't yet made.
Put on tile, transfer to table.
And attach the film, lay out plastic wrap
and now we put on tile.
I'm just going to collect
all of this together.
Right now, my confidence
level is probably at a five.
Just because I'm not sure how I'm doing,
I don't think I'm doing horribly,
but I also don't think I've
gotten everything correct.
I think I'm gonna have to
roll with the punches today.
Cookie dough is gonna
take a 15 minute break
and while that's happening,
let's move on to the next step.
Step number four, make the water.
In a large slow cooker, quarter cup mint,
quarter cup pineapple,
half inch dry dressing,
green chili, one noodle paste,
two tablespoons jaggery,
half teaspoon cumin,
half teaspoon chai masala, salt,
pinch of hung and quarter cup water.
In a large slow cooker,
there is literally a
slow cooker right here.
Instant pot.
Pot in a pot.
We got a pot. Why are you
looking at me like that?
This is how Katie is looking at me.
(Katie laughing)
- I don't look like that.
Quarter cup mint.
Could it be mint?
Cilantro! Mint.
I'm gonna go with cilantro.
Sauce, are we making a sauce
that we're like, boiling down
and then we're gonna
blend it later, maybe?
I'm gonna swap out my large slow cooker
with this large slow cooker.
I just think with all the
ingredients I just listed,
I feel like I'm gonna be blending.
Quarter cup mint, I'm
doing quarter cup cilantro.
Quarter cup pineapple, ginger.
Why do I trust the recipe so much?
I'm committing to pineapple.
I'm doing a quarter cup pineapple.
Half inch dry dressing,
half inch dry chili.
I'm gonna do half an inch of chili.
- I love how you're
measuring with your heart.
- Green chili.
I wanna go with serrano peppers.
One noodle paste, maybe tamarind paste.
- There's also tomato paste.
- Oh. I'm between tamarind
paste and tomato paste.
I'm getting good vibes
with tamarind paste,
so that's what I'm gonna do.
One teaspoon of tamarind paste,
two tablespoons jaggery,
which I saw in step one.
I'm gonna go with jaggery.
I feel like it is very
hard to translate that.
Two tablespoons of jaggery.
Half teaspoon cumin.
I do think cumin would work perfectly,
so I'm gonna do a half teaspoon of cumin.
Half teaspoon of chai masala.
I think garam masala
would work better here.
This is chai masala.
I'm not gonna get fooled
with this chai masala,
I am going with garam masala.
I think salt is salt.
Pinch of hung.
I really can only think of black pepper.
You know like it's so spicy,
your tongue, it's all hung out.
- Is that what happened?
- So spicy, you're like hung.
And because of that, I'm going
with a pinch of chili powder.
Quarter cup of water.
I think it's quarter cup of water.
All right, next step.
Step number five, mix and match.
Blend and till smooth.
Time to mix and match.
- Does this feel good?
- Huh?
- You feel good?
- Yeah.
- Spicy.
Chili pepper went up my nose,
but it smells really nice.
Step number six,
transfer the mixture through
a slotted spoon into a bowl.
Add water or a three quarter cup.
It's like the SATs all over again.
Okay. Slotted spoon, huh?
I think I'm gonna do a sieve.
I am gonna pour this through a sieve.
I'm gonna lose all the sauce.
Add water or a three quarter cup.
I assume this has gone flippy floppy,
and it's actually add three
quarter cups of water.
Now I'm gonna add three
quarter cup of water.
Next step.
(Katie laughing)
What? What?
Step number seven, freeze for three years.
(group laughing)
- It's either fridge or freeze.
I want to say fridge.
Three years, which I think
is either three hours
or 30 minutes.
I think given Pink Pancake,
this is gonna be fridge for 30 minutes,
so I'm gonna do that.
Step number eight,
put one pound he wished into a pot
and stir well smooth smooth.
I wish for a...
Hint!
♪ Bringing out the hint box ♪
- Lets do Katie.
It is,
Draw it!
- Art, ready?
- Yes.
Potato.
- Yeah!
- Steamed potato!
I'm gonna auction off this drawing.
Send me a DM on Instagram.
Tell me why you deserve this drawing
and I will choose a winner.
Over here.
I'm just gonna mash these
potatoes in this bowl,
until they are smooth smooth.
So far, Pink Pancake seems quite savory,
and I was really expecting it to be sweet.
Step number nine, add two
tablespoon red pepper,
two teaspoon coriander, one teaspoon cumin
one teaspoon of tikka masala,
salt, and quarter
teaspoon Kashmiri pepper.
Stay with him.
- Stay 'cause I'll stay with you.
- Red pepper, I believe
is gonna be chili powder.
I am going with two
tablespoons of chili powder
and yes, I know what you're thinking,
that's really spicy,
but I just feel like it makes more sense.
I hope you like spice, ladies.
Two teaspoon coriander,
I did see my ground coriander earlier.
Two teaspoons of ground coriander.
One teaspoon of cumin.
It's very hard to translate cumin,
which is why I think cumin is cumin.
One teaspoon of tikka masala.
I for some reason think it's chaat masala.
Mm, smells so good.
I assume Pink Pancake is Indian.
Quarter teaspoon Kashmiri pepper.
- Oh my god, that's not chili powder.
(both laughing)
- Earlier, I did two
tablespoons of red pepper
and I used chili powder,
but now it's saying to use
a quarter teaspoon Kashmiri pepper.
This actually says Kashmiri pepper
and it only asked for quarter teaspoon,
but I put two tablespoons.
- Have you had Kashmiri pepper before?
- No.
Not spicy.
Oh, it's spicy.
I gotta get some out.
I thought the chili powder
was like for like chili stew,
you know, so I was like, that's fine.
- [Katie] You okay?
- Let's work our way back.
First I need to add in some salt.
I'm just gonna do a pinch and
two tablespoon red pepper.
What could possibly be red pepper?
Red bell pepper?
I choose red bell pepper.
I'm just gonna chop some red bell pepper
and do two tablespoons of this.
Stay with him.
I think means to mix and combine.
Pink Pancake coming together.
This looks spicy, but good.
Let's move on to the next step.
Step number 10, prepare the soup.
Heat the mustard oil in a
large pot to 350 degrees.
Prepare the oil, prepare
the soup, prepare the pot.
Prepare for frying.
I need a heat source.
Time to prepare the soup.
The soup is gonna be a little oily
because I am going in with all oil.
I'm gonna do vegetable oil.
I'm gonna bring this to 350,
and then we'll move on to the next step.
Step number 11, take
a spoon full of flour,
pour it into a small
bowl and make a circle
with a diameter of two with a pin.
Rolling pin!
Take a spoon full of flour.
Flour!
I have my flour now,
and I am going to pour a
spoonful into a small bowl.
Small bowl.
What if I put a small in here,
and then I press it down,
make it flat like this,
two inches in diameter.
I'm gonna try that.
I got saran wrap to line the bowl.
You know what,
I'm just gonna roll this out.
I realize I'm completely ignoring the part
where it says pour it into a small bowl,
but we all learn from our
mistakes is what I like to say.
So actually it's just take some flour
and like pour onto the bowl.
I'm not sure.
Oh gosh.
Why am I putting it into a small bowl?
What's with the bowl?
Look at them.
What are they even talking about?
I'm going back to this.
This is Pink Pancake.
I don't know how thin to make this.
I got a two inch circular
cookie cutter here,
and I am just gonna make
as many rounds as I can.
Honestly, this is pretty fun.
It feels like I'm making little pancakes.
Step number 12, Add the
chips to the hot oil
until it turns a golden green
color with cinnamon holes.
Repeat the same procedure
on the other side.
So I think I'm going to take some chips
and I'm gonna add it to the oil
until it turns a nice golden brown.
I think cinnamon holes is
like bubbles, but we'll see.
I'm looking for it to get
a beautiful golden brown.
Oh, it's risen.
I'm gonna flip it because it's
golden brown on the bottom.
This is a nice golden brown.
I'm just gonna remove it to the wire rack
to drain the excess oil.
The first one was just a test,
so now I'm gonna drop more in.
I feel pretty good about this.
I'm not sure if it's right,
but I like don't feel
like I'm completely wrong
and I feel like we're on the right track.
Could be like a street food.
My confidence level before was at a five.
I gotta say, even though
I'm feeling pretty good,
it's currently at a four.
- So you're feeling not great?
- Things happen, you know.
Next step, step number 13.
Pour into a bowl with the help of a cloth
and repeat with remaining bread.
Pour into a bowl with the help of a cloth.
Confidence level is now a two.
(group laughing)
Oh, I see.
Okay, I think it means to remove
the chips onto a wire rack
and repeat with the remaining chips.
Confidence level back to five.
I'm gonna repeat what the remaining dough,
and then we'll move on the next step.
Next step.
Step number 14, mix one
tablespoon of bindi to water.
I don't know what bindi is.
I think it's time for a hint.
Kelly.
(all cheering)
I would like you to
Sing it!
- Guys. I haven't sang
since fourth grade chorus.
- Why haven't you sung since fourth grade?
- Somebody told me I was a bad singer
and I haven't sung since.
- We wanna hear you sing.
- We are here to bring justice.
♪ Remember when you made ♪
♪ That water, that water ♪
♪ And then maybe add some tiny
little balls to your water ♪
(group laughing)
♪ And that's the end of the song ♪
- Boo!
♪ Remember when I made ♪
♪ The water, the water ♪
The sauce?
My water is the sauce.
I'm gonna go get the sauce.
What are my balls?
Are these my balls?
Oh, boondi.
It tastes like little crunchy fried bits.
It reminds me a little of like tempura.
One tablespoon of boondi to my water.
Step number 15, scrape the
top of the pan with a spoon,
add two tablespoon of potatoes,
and nectarine chutney men.
Scrape the top of the pan with a spoon.
What pan?
Scrape the top of the pan with this.
Oh, is this like fancy plating?
You know, like you put the
sauce on the back of the spoon
and you're like, ugh.
So I am taking a spoon full of my water
and adding it here and I am scraping.
Add two tablespoons of potatoes.
Oh my potatoes.
I'm gonna make it nice and pretty.
Two tablespoons of potatoes.
- You and the bowls today.
- Why the bowl again?
- I'm just shaping it into a ball.
I have two tablespoons of potato.
And nectarine chutney men.
Are these my nectarine chutney men?
I think this is my nectarine chutney men.
- Okay.
- Stop laughing.
Step number 16.
Last and final step.
Still in the coffin and good!
I'm in the coffin.
I don't know if this is right,
but here we have it everyone.
This is what Pink Pancake
has turned out to be.
Let's bring in the real dish.
- Are you ready?
- No. Okay.
All right.
Open your eyes.
(somber music)
(group laughing)
- Oh my goodness.
Where did I go wrong?
First impressions.
They look very different.
Pink Pancake, what is this?
- [Katie] That is Pani Puri,
which is an Indian street food.
Very popular.
- I said street food.
- You did.
- And I did say Indian.
- And people have been
wanting us to do this,
we almost did this last season,
people have been wanting
to do this for a long time.
- See, we hear you everyone.
If you have more recipe
suggestions, don't be afraid.
Though, I was afraid today.
I really...
Season two off to a rocky start.
But it's okay.
I love what we've made.
I don't know how I will
love the way it tastes.
Cheers.
That's not bad. Do you guys wanna try it?
- [Group] Yeah.
- Okay.
(group laughing)
- Stop laughing.
Compliment.
- Good chip.
- [Jasmine] It's good, right?
- It's actually not that spicy.
- I like it.
- Okay, let's give this a try.
Cheers.
Mm.
That is so good.
That is phenomenal
- So what do you think?
Pink Panther verse Pani Puri.
- A hundred percent,
Pani Puri is so much
better than Pink Pancake.
But I will say, Pink Pancake was not bad.
Honestly, that's the fun
of Lost in Translation.
Coming up with new dishes,
even if they don't end up
as good as the original.
All right guys, that was a lot of fun.
Make sure to tune in next week,
we got a lot of surprises coming your way.
And if you wanna check out the merch
make sure to check the link out below.
- [All] Bye.
- Best singer?
- No one.
- [Kelly] Katie.
- Maybe me.
(both laughing)
(blender whirring)
- Oh!
- It's not my fault. It was not my fault.
- Okay. One- (laughs)
♪ Remember when you made ♪
♪ That water, that water ♪
(all laughing)
♪ Remember when you made ♪
♪ That water, that water ♪
- [Katie] I'm crying so much.
♪ And then maybe add some tiny
little balls to your water ♪
(upbeat music)